the nintendo switch it keeps building in
strength thanks to a library of great
first-party games and strong third-party
support with the flexibility of playing
while docked to a tv or as a hand-held
portable console it's a great way to
enjoy your favorite games whether you've
been a switch owner from the beginning
or perhaps earning the new oled version
there are plenty of upcoming games to
get excited about to help you find your
next gaming obsession which is
definitely going to be the good life to
help you find your next big old gaming
obsession we've compiled a list of the
biggest upcoming nintendo switch games
to watch out for over the next year if
you end up liking this video and want to
see more then well consider subscribing
to us
gamespot the advance warf series brought
some of the best tactical gameplay of
the game boy advance and nintendo ds era
now we get to revisit it with a fresh
new look in the form of advance wars 1
and 2 reboot boot reboot camp reboot
camp anyways it's a nintendo switch
remake for the first two games if you
didn't get that from the one and two in
the re okay featuring turn based
gameplay on a grid the advanced wars
games see you assume the role of one of
various commanding officers directing
troops to victory with each military
group capable of using game-changing
special abilities such as unit repairs
or power boosts developer way forward
known for games like river city girls
has got the job with the remake
breathing new life into the series that
will now feature online multiplayer in
addition to the campaigns and local play
included in the original release you'll
be able to suit up for battle when
advance wars one and two reboot camp
marches on to nintendo switch in spring
2022.
it seems as if we've known bayonetta 3
has been in development forever but
after a gameplay debut in fall 2021 its
release doesn't seem so distant anymore
with a confirmed release window of 2022
bayonetta is known for some of the most
deliriously camp action shooter gameplay
out there and bayonetta herself is as
charming as she is deadly defeating
hordes of angels and demons with flowing
locks of hair that'll make rapunzel
jealous it's for this reason and many
more that we think being a 3 is one of
the biggest upcoming nintendo switch
games
hollow knight stunned many of us with
this brilliant bug-filled take on the
popular metroidvania genre so its sequel
hollow knight silk song has to be one of
the most hotly anticipated indie games
hollow knight sports tight combat and
rewarding exploration and include some
of the best environmental storytelling
seen in any video game hollow knight
silk song stars hornet a protagonist
larger and more vertically nimble than
hollow knight's hero at exhibition demos
back in 2019 hornet's needle and silk
based abilities were simultaneously
familiar yet different making her a
satisfying refreshing character to play
mainly due to her abilities encouraging
greater verticality we're not sure when
hollow knight silk song is arriving on
nintendo switch but here's
hoping it's soon
just hold yep maybe holding out yeah
it'll be this year it's sometime soon
sure
nintendo debuted a new 3d kirby game in
the september 2021 nintendo direct and
like all great surprise announcements
it's already shockingly close to release
kirby's next adventure takes him to the
ruins of an open world environment
putting the pink puffball to work
exploring the remnants of an old
civilization that sounds more dark and
brooding than what kirby tends to get up
to but in practice the game looks as
charming and as cute as ever with
inspiration from games like super mario
odyssey this should be an adorable
little romp kirby in the forgotten land
are scheduled for release in spring 2022
the breath of the wild sequel which we
don't yet know the official title of has
us all clamoring for details with recent
trailer footage offering a tantalizing
glimpse into the setting we'll be
exploring in the near future including
that one really weird sweet part when
link turns into a drip of water and like
goes through the floor that that i'm
excited i'm me kurt narrator boy i'm
excited for that come on you big drip
where you going we've done our own
speculation as to what the next hyrule
adventure will entail going over the
symbolism used in an effort to decipher
what the zelda team has in store and
links to the written and video versions
of that will be in the description the
untitled sequel to legend of zelda
breath the wild will take to the skies
in an exciting attempt to reach the same
dizzying heights sometime in 2022
after remaining dormant since lego star
wars the force awakens in 2016
tt games is coming back to the franchise
that started its wildly successful
kid-friendly series with a soft reboot
lego star wars the skywalker saga will
encompass all nine numbered star wars
films making for the first time the
games have explored the most recent two
the last jedi and the rise of skywalker
but these are more than remasters
instead tt games is starting fresh by
rethinking the entire mechanical
foundation of lego star wars and making
new cutscenes to modernize the
long-standing action platformer
originally scheduled for 2020 the
release date has slipped a few times
it's currently due in early 2022.
nintendo and ubisoft's tactical
crossover with mario rabbids kingdom
battle surprised even the most rusted-on
genre veterans with its whimsical
setting and clever gameplay so we're
thrilled the sequel mario rabbids sparks
of hope is incoming this time around
mario and his rabid friends venture
forth to save the galaxy alongside
rabbit rosalina and rabid luma hybrids
known as sparks not content to rest on
the same grid based combat of its
predecessors mario rabbit's sparks of
hope includes more real-time combat
elements in addition to an increased
focus on overworld exploration beloved
video game composer grant kirkhope is
returning to score this one too so there
will be plenty of wonderful music to
listen to while you take on the
freshened up combat encounters mario
rabbids sparks of hope will bring its
corgi genre hybrid action to nintendo
switch during 2022.
alright look we don't know when to
expect metroid prime 4 especially in
light of development restarting at the
start of 2019 but retro studio's
collective pedigree alone is reason
enough to eagerly anticipate the
eventual release of the fourth metroid
prime entry the metroid prime series is
an outstanding first person adventure
game with shooter mechanics lauded for
its ability to generate immersion
through meticulous world building and
phenomenal sound design we certainly
hope to see metroid prime 4 in 2022 so
we can once again assume the role of
samus in what is to be expected another
brilliant space-faring adventure one
thing we do know for sure metroid prime
4 will be a nintendo switch exclusive
unless some weird twist of fate happens
and galaxies explode and the stars
dismantle and suddenly we've seen
nintendo characters on different
platforms chris pratt voices mario i
don't know
what is reality these days anyways
moving on
the studio best known for its
groundbreaking xcom games is back with
the marvel license midnight suns is a
turn-based tactical game based on the
marvel universe which brings together a
varied roster of characters including
iron man blade wolverine and ghost rider
the motley crew is brought together to
deal with a supernatural threat based
loosely on the 1990s comic series
joining them will be your own character
the hunter which can be customized with
up to 40 different abilities it's set to
come out in late 2022
monster hunterize was a great switch
entry in the popular action rpg series
receiving a stellar 9 out of 10 in
gamespot's review so obviously it gets
our attention when capcom announces a
sizable expansion that appears similar
in scope to monster hunter world's big
iceborn expansion sun break promises a
new story with more event quests and of
course new monsters and gear to craft
sun break is coming in summer 2022
pokemon legends arceus is shaping up to
be one of the most exciting new
additions to the series in years where
pokemon sword and shield took small
steps into open world exploration with
the wild area pokemon legends rks looks
to be going all in sat in the distant
past you play as an adventurer tasked
with creating the sinnoh region's first
pokeducks in a significant change to the
series pokemon legend's arceus appears
to take place in real time with catching
pokemon requiring you to aim and throw
pokeballs while they roam openly in the
wild its lush nature filled open world
setting has drawn comparisons to the
legend of zelda breath of the wild a
game that certainly makes for good
inspiration we'll find out more when
pokemon legends arceus hits nintendo
switch on january 28 2022
splatoon the family friendly inc shooter
is a big seller for nintendo so the
announcement of splatoon 3 was a welcome
inevitability the splatoon series has
captured imaginations worldwide with its
bright and fast paced gameplay fresh
music and the splatfests splatoon 3's
setting as shown in the reveal trailer
is a mad max style desert wasteland
which looks like quite a moody departure
from the previous two games but also a
fascinating location for waging turf
wars both splatoon games released so far
have been brilliant fun for all ages
which is exactly what we're expecting
when splatoon 3 splashes onto nintendo
switch sometime in 2022
from small indie team sidebar games
sports story is the follow-up to
charming rpg sport hybrid golf story
with the addition of several more sports
including tennis and soccer similar to
the mario golf and mario tennis games on
game boy color golf story combines
satisfying sports gameplay with rpg
elements such as leveling up stats and
acquiring better equipment alongside a
humorous story where every problem could
be solved by hitting a golf ball at it
which unfortunately is not something i
can do in real life when having to pay
my rent sports story was initially
slated for a 2020 release but was
delayed indefinitely due to its
increasing development scope at this
point well we're not sure when sports
story is going to bounce onto nintendo
switch consoles but let's just put it
out there and say 2022 and hit a golf
ball at it because that's how we solve
problems in this world
named after the weapon triangle system
of many turn-based strategy games it's
clear what you're going to get with
triangle strategy plenty of tactical
gameplay along with a deep story a
follow-up to square enix's gorgeous hd
2d rpg octopath traveler triangle
strategy takes more of a turn-based
strategy approach in telling a grand
tale about the salt iron war of factions
fighting for control over the valuable
resources of would you believe it salt
and iron what intrigues us most about
triangle strategy is its strong focus on
game altering choices by making
decisions based on utility morality and
liberty you shape the narrative and
affect who joins your cause with more
stunning pixel art technical gameplay
and a choice-based story to enjoy we're
awaiting more on triangle strategy ahead
of its march 4th 2022 release on
nintendo switch
and there you have it our most
anticipated switch games of 2022 and
beyond any other games you think are
worth a mention let us know down in the
comments below and if you like this
video consider clicking the like button
and subscribing too bad if you dislike
it because you can't see it because
youtube removed that function i'm sure
it'll be back soon
yeah
for more on everything nintendo switch
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you